cette vidéo trouvée par siby ci semble
montrer des hommes qui charge des
caisses remplies d'animaux sous un
soleil de plomb les images captées par
des témoins à l'aéroport de kiev et qui
ont circulé sur les médias sociaux
après douze heures de vol un avion de la
compagnie ukr/n internationals
atterrissait à l'aéroport de toronto la
semaine dernière avec à son bord
quelques 500 chiots notamment des
bouledogues français
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments qui supervise l'importation
d'animaux au pays a ouvert une enquête
l'organisme a découvert 38 animaux morts
et des dizaines d'autres malades ou
déshydraté dans cette cargaison
cette maîtresse de chiens
professionnelle a été témoin de leur
arrivée à toronto les employés de
l'aéroport était en état de choc
dit-elle la compagnie aérienne a décliné
toute demande d'entrevue mais dans une
déclaration sur les réseaux sociaux
elle affirme qu'elle collabore avec les
autorités locales selon des défenseurs
de la cause animale ce n'est pas la
première affaire du genre à survenir
comme un show il soutient que de grandes
usines à chiots en europe de l'est
profite d'un marché lucratif d'acheteurs
au canada et aux états unis les
bouledogues français par exemple peuvent
se vendre en ligne pour des milliers de
dollars et les clients ignorent souvent
d'où ils viennent exactement ce
professeur travaille avec les autorités
canadiennes sur les enjeux liés à
l'importation de masques d'animaux de
compagnie si certaines normes sont
établies on ignore la portée de ses
activités selon lui dans cette affaire
en particulier les autorités canadiennes
tentent de déterminer si des lois ont
été violées ici camille guiraud radio
canada toronto